us
it's kind of hard to tell exactly where
I wanna go but she's strange never
really got a chance to settle down much
England Germany Greenland yeah very
short yeah New Mexico
California California yeah Oklahoma and
I'm sure I'm missing something North
Carolina and you wonder where all these
influences come from people wonder I'm
like well it's pretty clear to me
strange had a military father and an
opera singer mother who he remains very
close with this song is called ratchet
okay he was raised in a strict Christian
household you didn't hear secular music
until when
um really when my friends started
getting cars and I could drive or like
ride in a car and listen to what they
were listening to and I would get like
little hints of secular music I'd have
like a babysitter and I'd watch TRL and
I'd be like whoa Backstreet Boys
what a thing I remember the NSYNC
performance on Disney Channel so your
first introduction to non-Christian
music was the Backstreet Boys
and in sync yeah Millennium album pretty
pretty sick album honestly we used to
sing it at weddings like a bunch of guys
we'd do like yeah we do like
performances from dude that's good it
was like I want it that way that's very
good music that was it you are my fire
yes the one desire we're not using this
in the piece
use it
after spending years in New York playing
on subways and a wide range of bands
strange settled in Washington D.C where
he is home his own captivating
alternative music
[Music]
[Applause]
safe to say with respect
it does not sound like a boy band
one TV on the radio was a big influence
yeah the first time I saw them I was
like on my mom's couch channel surfing
and the first thing I see is like these
three black guys on stage and they look
kind of like me if you look at it you
know the history of that music is Rich
with black artists like very rich but
when you look at like the alternative
music scene or like the indie rock scene
or the guitar driven scene of today you
don't see a lot of black people there's
some great ones you know you got like
Brittany Howards your Dev Heinz is you
know your Frank Ocean's like pretty
special art but it's not a lot you know
and I kind of wanted to create music to
kind of like assert that you know and be
like no like not only am I like do I
belong here but like there's a lot of
history that would like predicate that
you know that would like support that
how do you describe your music I just
describe it as myself
um I was talking to someone the other
day though and I kind of came came up
with the phrase it's like black
Americana the most famous old band of
this generation may be the national
years ago strange released an album of
national covers
they're so good dog crazy band I just
went on toward them like a month ago you
did I saw the the short you posted on
YouTube the first night I was so nervous
in Calgary I forgot the words and just
stood there on stage like an idiot no I
did blanked
in front of like 3 000 people
and but then by the next night I nailed
the rest of them
[Music]
where do you want your music to go
I have high hopes for myself and I'm a
pretty competitive person
[Music]
I see myself making big songs one day I
want to make huge chart topping songs
and I want to win Grammys there's
nothing like shooting for the moon yeah
I mean I've always wanted that and uh it
took me a long time to be able to say
that
but at this stage in my life I'm pretty
sure of that so that's the goal